this is Jocko underground podcast number
59. with Echo Charles and me Jocko
willink sitting here with another theory
to think about
got a theory for you to think of about
one to be aware of these theories are
good to be aware of when you're aware of
things you become so much more powerful
in defending against them I mean just
think about if you know what an arm lock
is you can defend the arm lock you don't
know what the unlock is you didn't know
where to start okay so here's a theory
it's called birdian's ass whose theory
is this it's a theory okay
the it is a
philosophical Paradox related to
decision making
it's named after this French philosopher
Jean birdian
it actually kind of makes fun of Gene
birdian and I won't go into the whole
history behind that because this guy's
somebody that was born in 1301
so this guy's
he's he's pretty ancient philosopher but
here here so here's the Paradox and I
guess he was he was a guy that
talked about this type of Free Will and
whatnot
but here's the paradox
if you place a donkey
an ass if you place a donkey that is
equally hungry and thirsty
and you you place him in equal distance
between water and food
he's going to die of both hunger and
thirst because he can't make a rational
decision between going to the hay or
going to the water all right so
it's something very good to be aware of
because this can happen to us this can
lead to paralysis
we get stuck in these situations where
it's like well that seems pretty good
but this seems pretty good too we just
don't make a decision or I want this but
I also want that so I'm just not going
to do anything
so it is a good time to employ
the law of combat prioritizing execute
right I mean in this case guess what
you can live for 30 days without food
you can only live three hours a three
you can live for 30 days about food you
can only live for through three days
without water so you better go get the
water first that's your prioritize and
execute model
no Factor
also can be a good time to employ some
iterative decision making like like oh
maybe I'll take a little step in this
direction do it oh yeah that makes sense
I'm still thirsty I can survive a little
bit longer without food but if I I need
water for sure
so take some small steps in that
direction but oftentimes we go through
life and sometimes we act like a jackass
we don't make decisions
we don't make decisions we don't choose
a course and listen I say and I don't
know when I started saying this but I've
been saying it I'm kind of sticking with
it right now okay
in my opinion seven out of 10 times 7
eight percent of the time action is
better than in action
except look there's three times where
you know what you gotta hesitate you
gotta hold back you gotta wait but most
of the time
action is better and the reason it's
better is because when you take action
you get to see a different perspective
you get a reaction your knowledge grows
you learn
you can learn by sitting and waiting
occasionally that's why it's only three
out of ten bro it's only three out of
ten
in action
has a possibility of giving you nothing
like you sit and wait you don't you
don't change your Viewpoint you don't
change your perspective you're seeing
the same thing that you saw before so
there's a chance that inaction do you
get nothing from it
there's a small chance that if I sit
here and wait and I see what echo's
going to do now I see what he's doing
okay now I can there's a chance
but there's also a chance that I don't
get to see anything new whereas if I
maneuver take a step take some action
I'm gonna get to see more I'm gonna
learn so
bottom line is
don't be a jackass
don't don't be a jackass take some
action don't get stuck don't sit there
and analyze all day long because it's
going to be a problem so there you go
little Theory little Theory from the
past from a from burdian's ass do you
ever forget that feeling
uh I don't know I didn't even think
about that I should have thought of it a
personal example of that
of me I think for I think for me it
might be I want this but I also want
that like at the same time which is what
the donkey's doing right the donkey
wants water and wants hay yeah so yeah
sometimes you're like oh I want this but
I also want that which one should I get
yeah and I'm and I wait and argue about
it in my own head yeah so don't do that
yeah that's true it feels like this is
something different though right feels
like it's different than what than just
one you know like if you want something
let's say it's like buying something
it's kind of like that's a common thing
where it's like yeah of course you want
both you probably want 10 other things
as well but these are just the two
things that you're considering and then
you're like wait but I only want to
spend a certain amount of money which
can only afford me one of these things
I'm sure that's like a common thing
that's not like this philosophical well
here's the thing you want to buy that
property and you want to buy this
property and you're like debating and
all of a sudden property goes up on the
prices go up on both all right yeah and
now you're being indecisely oh yeah
you're right yeah yeah so that's where
it applies or hey I Really Wanna I
really want to apply for this job but I
like this job as well yeah and you're
like oh which one should I apply for oh
I didn't apply for either one because I
was debating and guess what now both
jobs are filled so there's a bunch of
examples where this happens in real life
so like let's say you're walking in the
movie theater and then you're like
hey like over if I sit over there I'll
be around way less people but then if I
sit over there I'll have like the
perfect view but I'll be next to these
people but I have the perfect view it's
like right in the center yeah you know
kind of thing and you're like shoot
should I let me see oh wait there's more
people sitting over there a little bit
so maybe this one seems better now oh
shoot oh now everyone's side right there
kind of a thing yeah and you missed it
yeah that's my my turmoil usually it's
your your Vietnam actually
it's a quote Theo Von actually here's
the worst one this is probably gonna be
the worst one you ever heard maybe maybe
not I don't know so today it was today
um I was doing actually sorry not today
yesterday deadlifts after squats do you
do deadlifts after squats no how do you
split that deadlifts on a totally
different okay so I did that list after
squats
so I take the squat the weight room it's
very revealing yeah as to like your
effort level on your squats no my
deadlifts and your dad lives yeah no
just the deadness
um
in my head so I take the weights from
the squat rack when I'm done to and then
I start to load them on the deadlift
it's a different separate bar so when I
load one played on you know you won't
play at a time right so I got two one
plate on each side so the second plate
when I walk it from the squat rack to
the deadlift area or whatever like I
can't decide which side
this is weird
because if I walk it to The Far Side I'm
calculating weight so it depends on
which side I grab it from the squat rack
so if I grab it from The Far Side of the
squat rack should I walk it all the way
there then I'm done with it and then
I'll contribute to the recovery I have
from you know as far as the time
perspective or should I just go nuts To
Nuts Go Far Side
to nearsight
nearside to far side to even it up you
see what I'm saying so I don't know
where to put it just for a little bit
Yeah I think with the part of the theory
that applies to this is the part that's
called jackass
because none of that matters real
jackass yeah you're just like you need
to do something else like with your mind
it's real because that's just horrible
but when you said that that's the first
thing I thought I was like yeah Bradley
it's real because like and that's
that's kind of why at first I didn't
think that your example was because
that's like common that's like yeah no
no kidding like you're gonna be
indecisive because both provide benefits
like that's common that's that doesn't
deserve a theory almost that's how it
feels I don't know I'm not a philosopher
yeah
but let's not get trapped let's not be a
jackass there's no butt here but
sometimes there's like unreasonable this
will apply or this will pop up in your
head in an unreasonable way like it does
with me sometimes apparently so that's
why it deserves like a theory that's
what it felt like the whole system
worked but either way it applies to I
think it applies to everything
no matter what yeah okay first question
let's get to the questions bro
I'm 18. you just said do yourself a
favor that's really do us all a favor
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
8.18 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance at
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized